hey everyone its air threats Turner
sorry end comm and today we're going to
compare some medications we're going to
look at ace inhibitors and ARBs and as
always whenever you get done watching
this YouTube video you can access the
free quizzes that will test you on these
two medications so let's get started
in our previous lectures we went in
depth over ace inhibitors and ARBs but
now let's do a quick review so we can
see the similarities and the differences
so when you take an exam you can easily
differentiate between these two
medications so we have ace inhibitors a
stands for angiotensin converting enzyme
ARB stands for angiotensin 2 receptor
blockers now these medications affect
rass they do it in different ways
however they both achieve the same
results now what is wrath well rice is
the renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system
but what does this system do well it
manages our blood pressure
specifically whenever it drops and the
whole goal of Wrath is to get
angiotensin 2 on board because it is a
major active vasoconstrictors if we can
vaso constrict
other things we can increase our blood
pressure we increase blood pressure we
maintain tissue perfusion so what
happens with rafts is that whenever the
blood pressure drops the kidneys some
cells in the kidneys will sense this and
they will release renin when marooning
goes into the circulation it is going to
stimulate a substance that is in the
liver called angiotensinogen and
angiotensinogen is going to turn into
angiotensin 1 well we got to get to
angiotensin 2 so to do that ace will
help us out that is angiotensin
converting enzyme it's going to convert
angiotensin 1 into angiotensin 2 so
we're there we have this major
vasoconstrictor present but it has to
bind to some receptors because then we
can get things going so one type of
receptor that this angiotensin 2
is going to bind to is called an
angiotensin ii receptor site type 1 and
whenever angiotensin ii binds with those
type 1 receptors it is going to lead to
the results we need it's going to cause
vasoconstriction of our smooth vessels
so when we constrict vessels that is
going to clamp down and is that that is
going to help increase blood pressure
increase our systemic vascular
resistance in addition we are going to
trigger the release of a substance
called aldosterone by the adrenal cortex
and the whole reason for this is to help
increase blood volume because if we can
increase blood volume we constrict our
vessels we are definitely going to
increase blood pressure and maintain
tissue perfusion and to do this is this
aldosterone will cause the kidneys to
keep sodium in water but excrete
potassium now let's look at how these
two medications affect rats because
remember they do it in different ways
but they achieve the same results and
really what they're targeting is this
angiotensin 2 so let's look at ace
inhibitors what ACE inhibitors are going
to do is they are going to inhibit ACE
hence their name so they inhibit this
part of rass they prevent angiotensin 1
from turning into angiotensin 2 so we
don't have angiotensin 2 being able to
do its job
now ARBs what it's going to do is it's
going to inactivate the angiotensin ii
receptor sites type 1 so we will have
the conversion of angiotensin 1 to
angiotensin 2 you have a snoo in its job
but what we're going to prevent is as
angiotensin 2 being able to bind with
these type 1 receptors so you don't get
the effects of angiotensin 2 so as you
can see they're both affecting
angiotensin ii ace inhibitors is just
preventing this ace ARBs it's preventing
the activation of these receptor sites
either way they are affecting how Angie
to works therefore with both of these
medications what they're going to
achieve is that they're going to cause
vasodilation instead of vasoconstriction
so that's going to decrease systemic
vascular resistance and decrease the
blood pressure and it's going to make it
a little bit easier on the heart to pump
and here in a moment where we talk about
what these drugs are used for you'll see
why they're beneficial on some patients
in addition they're both going to
decrease that secretion of aldosterone
which again was to help increase our
blood volume so instead of keeping
sodium and water we're going to excrete
it but they will cause the kidneys to
keep potassium so we really have to
watch out for hyperkalemia in these
patients who take these drugs now some
other things you want to remember to
help you differentiate between them is
how their generic name is what is it
specifically in with with ACE inhibitors
the generics are going to end with pril
like lisinopril with ARDS the generics
will end with Soren like losartan so
when you're looking at the meds and
you're trying to turn exist an ace or
ARB look at the ending of those generic
names it'll really help you and another
thing I want to point out is with ace
inhibitors some patients not all can
develop this persistent nagging dry
cough and the reason for that is because
of how this ACE inhibitor is influencing
this ACE enzyme that is converting
angiotensin 1 into angiotensin 2 over
here with ARBs a dry persistent nagging
cough is not likely and a lot of times
if a patient does develop this dry
persistent cough with an ace the
physician may put them on an ARB because
that will help clear that up so the
reason for that is because ace normally
will inactivate a substance called Brady
Kannan Brady Kannan is an inflammatory
substance and what it will do is a
little break it down so don't and
activate it but if we're blocking this
by throwing on an ACE inhibitor we're
not going to be in
debating this Brady cotton so it can
increase and it can cause this coughing
another thing with ace inhibitors that
you want to watch out for as the nurse
is something that can happen called
angio edema
this is where you have swelling of the
deep tissues and it can present up
swelling of the face the tongue the lips
and it can cause a difficulty breathing
and if that happens that's a medical
emergency it's less likely to happen
with an ARB so there's a low chance of
it happening but you always just want to
monitor for that as well now let's wrap
up this review and let's talk about what
these medications are used for and look
at our nursing interventions and our
patient education together
so water ace and ARBs used to treat well
we've already learned that they help
lower the blood pressure so they're
great in helping patients who have
hypertension managing that blood
pressure keeping it low in addition
patients who have heart failure this is
where the heart muscle is damaged and it
can't really pump so it's not really
maintaining cardiac output plus blood
can backflow go into the lungs lead to
pulmonary edema and how ace and ARBs
will work is that they can help decrease
the after load in the preload on the
heart making it easier to pump and get
blood out to maintain cardiac output in
addition ace and arts can be used after
a patient has a myocardial infarction
again just helping the heart pump easier
after it's been damaged and these
medications can help decrease the
progression of diabetic nephropathy in
those patients who have type 2 diabetes
now what is diabetic nephropathy well
this is kidney disease caused by
diabetes and whenever a patient has
kidney disease those little nephrons and
the kidneys are affected because that's
a functional unit of the kidney that
doesn't work and they really lose the
ability to filter the blood very well so
protein will start to leak into the
urine well if you have high blood
pressure you're increasing the amount of
protein that's going into the urine well
if we throw an ace and Arbonne that can
help lower the blood pressure which will
decrease
now a protein that's going into the
urine hints slowing down our kidney
disease so these medications have like
that renal protective mechanism now what
are some patient education and things
you want to watch out for
eisenerz well we've learned that this
meant these medications can increase the
potassium level with the way that it
affects aldosterone because aldosterone
is not really going to be released so
now the kidneys are going to start
keeping potassium so there's a risk for
hyperkalemia therefore you want to
monitor the potassium levels but you
want to tell the patient to avoid
consuming a diet really high in
potassium so watch those salt
substitutes that have potassium and
those foods that are high in potassium
like spinach avocados bananas etc
because I can increase our potassium
levels in addition you want to talk to
the patient about how to prevent a
condition called rebound hypertension
this is where the blood pressure will
get so high it'll be hard to actually
bring the blood pressure down and this
tends to happen when a patient just
abruptly quits taking their ace or their
arm so educate the patient about the
importance of never just quit taking the
medication because sometimes patient
let's say they're started on an ACE
inhibitor they develop that dry nagging
persistent cough it's driving them crazy
and it's driving everyone else around
them crazy because they keep coughing so
they may just quit taking the medication
but instead of doing that they need to
talk to their doctor and their doctor
can switch them to something else where
they won't have that dry cough so just
let them know that that can happen if
they just abruptly quit taking it in
addition they need to make sure they're
monitoring their blood pressure at home
they need to get a device they need to
write down the recordings of what their
blood pressure is daily doing this is
best because we want to make sure that
these medications are in fact managing
their blood pressure or are they still
hypertensive or is it too much they're
hypotensive
so definitely communicate that to them
and lifestyle changes that they need to
do if they're taking these medications
to help lower the blood pressure let
them know that anti hypertensive
medications are not
cure for high blood pressure they need
to manage their diet by eating healthy
exercising or quit smoking if they're
smoking to help with that as well so we
want to monitor the potassium level as
we discussed over here because of
hyperkalemia but we also want to look at
the liver enzymes making sure the liver
is not being affected and renal function
because in some patients who are
dependent on the RAF's because let's say
they have severe heart failure with
severe heart failure or their cardiac
output isn't that great so they depend
on this rafts to maintain cardiac output
for them so if we give them an ace and
an ARB which affects Rask that's really
going to cause some kidney issues so we
want to be making sure we monitor the BU
in the creatinine what's the renal out
there urinary output is at least 30 CC's
an hour
are they having any abnormal swelling
going on in their body where they're
retaining fluid and lastly you want to
talk to the patient about this cough
that can happen with these ACE
inhibitors and if they can't tolerate it
what should they do and remember they
can be switched to arms which doesn't
have that dry persistent cough now one
thing you really want to watch out for
if you're working with patients who have
heart failure and they're on an ACE
inhibitor let's say that all of a sudden
they get this coffee well you want to
further investigate this call if you
don't want to just write it off oh it's
that coffee that you get with ace
inhibitors because with heart failure
they their heart will be weak the blood
will back up into the lungs or they'll
get pulmonary edema so they'll start
getting a call but this coffee will be
like a wet COFF you'll hear crackles if
you listen to their lungs
they'll have difficulty breathing with
just any movement like movie from the
bedside chair to the bed they get really
winded so you want to make sure that is
this just that Koff that you get with
ace inhibitors which is dry it's not
gonna be have crackles or wet or is this
heart failure exacerbation so make sure
you look at that in addition educate the
patient about this angioedema that's
more likely to happen with the ACE
inhibitors but
can happen with ARBs it's less likely
it's rare to but educate them about the
swelling of the face the mouth the lips
difficulty breathing and let them know
that's a medical emergency and that they
should seek attention immediately okay
so that wraps up this review over ace
inhibitors versus ARBs
thank you so much for watching don't
forget to take the free quiz and to
subscribe to our channel for more videos